stargate is better than star trek it
just is
and here's why
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
so i'm going to do a short series of
videos about why i honestly think
stargate sg1 in particular is better
than star trek
i'm going to break it down into a few
little categories
and i'd love to know what you think
please if you are new to the channel
like and subscribe the bell notification
but more importantly get into the
comments tell me which one you prefer
star trek stargate first video though
we're going to look at humor
[Laughter]
so in real life humor is really really
important and in my experience the more
stressful a job you do or the more
stressful a situation you're in the more
humor becomes important and sometimes
the much more darkening becomes
important
when i see tv shows and they say oh it's
gritty drama realistic i always wonder
where's the humor because they don't
tend to have any
star trek
tries to be funny sometimes
now i recently watched star trek the
final frontier and that film generally
is almost a comedy it's actually not as
bad as i remember them going to meet god
and everything was a bit of a silly
story plot but no more silly than them
going to save wales and bring them back
to the future to save mankind and you
know we all love that movie
nuclear
wessels
excuses oh excuse me uh we are looking
forward
so why didn't star trek the final
frontier work well i gotta admit it was
quite badly directed well done
um it was quite badly written also well
done and the storyline is pretty bad but
in all honesty the humor is
borderline silly and star trek have
tried this repeatedly we all remember
that bit in star trek generations with
data with again they try to inject some
humor and when they're about to crash
and it pans across to him and he goes oh
[ __ ]
it's not funny it's supposed to be but
it just doesn't work and that to be
honest goes on and on and on now star
trek at times can be light-hearted and
that works
extraordinary consequences of creating a
new life
does that not describe becoming a parent
sir
works but when they try to be funny it
generally fails please like i said get a
comment tell me are there any really
honestly funny bits in star trek that
you can tell me about because i've
ranked my brains and i can't really
think of any
chicken sandwich
[Music]
this is my chicken sandwich and coffee
now stargate on the other hand
was always funny but it was also
believably funny
like i say in stressful situations
people tend to use humor as a coping
strategy
that's the kind of humor that we saw in
stargate particularly stargate sg1
richard dean anderson actually demanded
it when he was doing his negotiations
for the series to come back he said i
want this guy to be have little quippy
jokes and lose this you know to be quite
sarcastic character now they worked that
in over the first series they didn't
want to go too far away from kurt
russell's version of colonel o'neill but
they worked that in by the end of the
series he was the jack o'neill that we
came to love do you recognize any of
this i do not generally have it
nope
neither do i
i'm just saying but there was always
other elements of comedy as well that
again always worked but were believable
you know sometimes they would take the
mickey a little bit out of teal he
didn't know the
you know the little jokes and about
movies and things like this that they
made so these little pop references
lucy i'm home
i am not lucy
i know that there's a reference to an
old tv
never mind open the door
i will summon the doctor no no come on
i'm fine back to being myself just open
up
i cannot be certain you're back to being
yourself
you refer to me as lucy
see smiley friendly
you're gonna have to work on that a
little bit
give me a warning
i'm going to shoot you
i was thinking more along the lines of
on three
one
two
they made jokes about how him being a
jaffa was different and he didn't
understand some of those things so they
poke funny also they poke fun of how
serious he was you know they used his
little catchphrase indeed brilliantly in
a lot of clips to make it very very
funny but then we had episodes
do you know what i'm talking about here
run the clip earlier with their arrival
on p4x639
now this word here
uh deductable is a variation of deduct
okay this section of the text seems to
deal primarily with their arrival on p4x
639 this appears to be a reference to
the gradual degeneration of the machine
itself
the foundation of a colony
guys you getting this because this is
important unscheduled activation
from you
should we not be assisting daniel
jackson with the translation
i'm taking this loop off
well think about it i mean if you know
in advance that everything is always
going to go back to the way it was then
you could do anything
for as long as you want without having
to worry about consequences
[Music]
excuse me
[Music]
oh yeah
that'll play
how far is alaris anyway
several billion miles
that's gotta be a record
[Music]
excuse me george
what are you doing out of uniform
handing you my resignation
resigning
so i can do
this
[Music]
what are you smiling at
nothing
that we're just funny from beginning to
end
the 200th episode again in places is
properly laugh out loud hilarious
but again
it's humor that works because it's the
kind of humor that i know working in the
nhs working for my local government
council things like this
the people will say in real life people
are genuinely sarcastic and particularly
in very stressful situations
for me that is more realistic and more
gritty than any serious drama can be but
tell me what you think which is the
funniest series and does the humor in
the series actually matter because i
think it really does i think it's really
important i think it makes it more
realistic like i say and please let me
know are there any other reasons why you
think star trek is just not as good as
stargate
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out and
also you can consider becoming a fully
fledged site tracker hit the join button
it really supports the channel
as always please stay safe i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you